okay we were just talking about false
narratives which leads us quite smoothly
into our top headline and this is a big
headline because apparently if you can
believe it a United States congresswoman
was a victim of a racist incident inside
the capito building uh I mean you really
can't go anywhere uh these days to
escape from racism can you it's just
it's everywhere so here's Democratic
representative Barbara Lee last night
listen these are not little kinks first
of all racism institutional racism is in
the D of this country when you look at
uh what has taking place look at the our
Native Americans the genocide of Native
Americans when you look at what is
taking place as it relates to
African-Americans uh the 250 years plus
of enslaving African-Americans and then
you look at the disparities now uh in
our community in terms of health care un
unemployment the wealth Gap housing you
can't tell me the systemic racism does
not exist it's not just a little King I
do want to cut that off uh just for a
second we haven't got into her personal
story of racist vict victimization yet
and it's quite a it's a doozy so we'll
get there in a second but but um we have
to note that the Preamble she offers
here about systemic racism is totally
false um speaking again of leftist
premises you know that are false uh we
hear this familiar Trope about the
genocide of Native Americans there was
no genocide of Native Americans we are
we are the only country in the world
that would invent a genocide that we
perpetrated okay like our modern fables
of American History are all centered
around making us the bad guys our our
new um sort of foundational myths are
all centered around making us the bad
guys and that's that's the exact
opposite of how these myths and fables
usually work but you know we're the most
self-loathing Society that's ever
existed on Earth it's a sickness and
that's where you get this Native
American genocide thing uh Europe
European settlers and later Americans
fought Wars against the Indians uh these
wars lasted for many many years these
were Wars with lots of hostility on both
sides uh it was a war it's a battle many
many battles um hundreds of years really
it was a series of battles it was it was
um and and that's it you know it wasn't
it wasn't like one war it wasn't a
constant state of allout War all over
the country all over the continent
rather but this land was conquered
partly through a series of battles over
many years that's not a genocide that's
how a land is conquered fair and square
it's how the native tribes conquered it
themselves and then it's how they
themselves were conquered and uh and
also besides you know more Indians died
by disease than anything else and that
also is not a genocide it's not these
were not biological weapons they weren't
dropping bombs or whatever they were
this is not that they weren't they
weren't making viruses in a lab in Wuhan
um a lot of this was happening before
the germ theory of disease had been
fully devised anyway so um so it's not a
genocide all right and speaking of
things so that didn't happen but
speaking of things that that also didn't
happen um let's continue secondly you
have personal racism which is hard to
address but I'll give you one little
story that shows you why uh we need to
understand that I don't think she really
understands racism I was walking from
the house building on Capitol Hill to
the Capal and a man a white guy stopped
me and told me I could not get into the
members elevator and you know we have uh
pens and I was going to vote and he
blocked me from getting into the
elevator and told me I was not a member
of Congress and it was for members only
I said sir I'm a member of Congress and
he I showed him my pen and he said whose
pen did you steal now this is an example
of what personal racism is and how
people of color constantly have to deal
with this each and every day but
systemic racism is in the policies of
this country and just look at what
they're trying to do in terms of
eliminating diversity equity and
inclusion they're trying to uh not allow
for an equal and Level Playing Field uh
and so it's a very dangerous uh position
that she has uh she's clueless well
that's a shame and I'm sorry that that
you had to deal with that congresswoman
thank you for sharing that with us now
of course Caitlyn Collins the anchor uh
just sits there staring blankly and
doesn't ask any follow-up questions at
all uh it's it's it's almost like she
knows the story is completely made up so
she doesn't want to
because actually if you believed it then
you'd have a lot of questions like who
was this random white guy blocking the
elevator like just a guy was that was it
a security guard and if it was a
security guard did you report this
incident to his superiors is the guy
fired and and if he's a security guard
that he when he works there you how
could he not recognize you and know that
you're a representative of uh and and I
mean was this his first day on the
job and if it was was he stopping every
non-white member of Congress who walked
by like did he not know is this a
security guard working in on Capitol
Hill who is not aware that non-white
people are also representatives was this
a security guard who came here in a time
portal from the year 1803 and just was
unfamiliar with the concept of non-white
congressional
Representatives I mean we've had black
people in Congress since like 1870 okay
so this guy would I I guess he came from
before that um this is a uh uh you know
he came in a time machine from or maybe
the guy's like 200 years old he's a 200y
old rookie security guard who was
looking for a change of career later in
life and he got to Congress and he
looked around he said what's what's
going on here um maybe it wasn't a
security guard was it a staffer did some
white staffer go up to a black
congresswoman and accuse her of stealing
her pin is that it so so this is someone
who just decided randomly out of nowhere
to completely nuke their own future
political career did some Stafford
decide to commit a suicide bombing of
his own
career because that seems very strange
or what or was it another member of
Congress and if so who are we supposed
to believe that Barbara Lee was accosted
by some Racist congressman and and what
through her through her abiding sense of
Mercy she's decided to not tell us the
guy's
name really is that what we're supposed
to believe so a white Republican Racist
congressman uh accosted her and but
she's not going to tell us who she's
yeah I don't want to get the guy in
trouble right are you one of the
millions of American men and women
dealing with premature hair loss maybe
you're scared about inheriting that
thinning look because it runs in the
family well you can start 2024 off the
right way with a real solution that
delivers on its promise without the
harsh side effects unwanted chemicals
and no need for a prescription provia
uses a safe natural ingredient called
prael to effectively Target the three
main causes of premature hair thinning
and loss by supporting healthy scalp
circulation the delivery of nourishing
nutrients and healthy hair follicle uh
follicle anchoring to your scalp provia
guarantees more hair on your head than
in the shower or on your comb and it's
effective for men and women of any age
and safe on colored treated and styled
hair it's that easy and right now new
customers save over 50% plus free
shipping on provia introductory package
at provia.com Walsh every package
includes a full 60-day supply of provia
serum for daily use plus the provia
super concentrate for faster more
noticeable results and every order
includes your choice of free gift right
now at checkout provia Works guaranteed
or 100% of your money back don't wait
order now and save an extra 10% and uh
free shipping at provia.com Walsh that's
provia.com
Walsh of course it's impossible to
believe any of these scenarios um uh or
at least well I'm not going to say it's
impossible to believe
because uh you know it's it is
technically possible like anything's
technically possible she could have told
me that um she was walking through the
halls of Congress and she saw somebody
uh
levitating you know off the ground it's
like I mean it's it's not it's
technically
possible in the sense that anything
that's logically possible is is
therefore
possible in fact well that's actually
even more because that's that that would
bring to mind demonic possession or
something and I so that in fact I would
probably readily believe that so maybe
that's not the best example to prove my
point but you get it so but anyway uh
are any of these scenarios here's the
real question are any of these scenarios
remotely close to as likely as the far
more plausible scenario that barbar Lee
just made it up you know so you've got
all these it could have been a congress
it could have been a security guard from
U from from a time machine from the past
could be like I can't it's it's possible
time machines could exist
maybe uh could be a staffer who just
decided like I'm going to ruin my entire
career for no
reason um could have been a congressman
whose identity she's protecting because
she's just so
kind uh or or it could be that she just
made this
up um
and of course that's what what's
happening and she made it up like none
of this happened she made it up uh so
what could possibly the more interesting
question the question of whether or not
that happened is not interesting because
we all know that it just flat out didn't
um I mean I'll bet $10,000 right now
that it didn't happen but the more
interesting question is what could
possibly possess her to randomly invent
This Racist incident that definitely
didn't
happen that to me is the interesting
question and I think the answer is that
it's a reflex at this point like on the
left inventing stories of victimhood is
is Instinct it's reflexive it's like a
it's it's like a hiccup okay it's this
almost involuntary physiological
response they blurred out race hoaxes
without even thinking about them that's
how severe the self- victimhood
obsession has become it's how ingrained
their desire for victimhood
is and that's why that's why it must be
great you know to be a a black person in
a room full of Libs it's got to be great
I'm I'm a little bit of jealous I have
to admit because the trolling
opportunities are
tremendous because if you're a black
person in a room full Liv you could you
can make up any story that you want and
they will accept it at face value with
no further
questions which which is amazing but you
could walk in and say hey guys sorry I'm
late uh I was uh I was uh I was just
assaulted by a group of five racist Nazi
ninjas on the way in here and uh
fortunately I was able to fight them off
with my Superior swordsmanship uh which
I learned from my years studying uh
martial arts in Japan and and yeah no
matter what you say they'll they'll
accept it
and without without any follow-up
questions at
all and
um and it's possible to do because this
kind of victim self-victimization
whether it's racial whether it's race
based self victimization uh it's gender
based sexual orientation based whatever
it is it's it's just reflexive like I I
don't even it's interesting to to to
think like did did Barbara
Lee go into that
interview having already invented this
fake story and planning on saying it
that's possible but I also think it's
quite possible that she didn't even plan
on making that up she just did she could
hear herself making this up while she
was saying it and then she said okay I
guess this is what we're doing because
it's such a reflex for them um pretty
amazing it's it's also you know you look
at you go on Twitter or or if Caitlyn
Collins tweeted out this um this video
herself obviously in a non-skeptical way
and I mean every single comment is from
people saying oh did they yell did he
yell this is magga country too bar
Barbara Smet like that's every comment
like nobody believes this stuff anymore
no one Falls for
it um and it also shows you how out of
touch the media is that like Caitlyn
Collins if she had any kind of awareness
she would know that most people are not
going to believe that nonsense and so
she wouldn't tweet out the clip she
would she she would rather just pretend
it never happened because it's
embarrassing but she Caitlyn Collins
lives in a world where people still buy
this
garbage if You' like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there Godspeed